on our top story and the foreign
secretary liz trust has said the
atrocities in butcher and ukraine need
to be investigated as war crimes after
images have emerged of ukrainian
civilians lying dead on the streets near
the city of kiev joining us now from
spain is the ukrainian
mp at lisa yaska um hi lisa thank you
for joining us uh the images from
butcher um all over the front pages here
in the uk this morning
your heart must bleed when you see them
exactly
for me uh seeing that and knowing what's
happening what's happening there and
what happens
and losing quite many people are already
new
uh
in in this work
it's devastating and something that you
cannot
um
you cannot adjust to you cannot accept
but in the same time every day it's
happening and
um i have a hope every day that tomorrow
will be different but
unfortunately
there are more and more victims coming
and if we don't act
very decisively in the world to end this
war
uh to show more strengths to give more
military assistance to ukraine
i will continue seeing this as many as
other people in ukraine this atrocities
and this victims and it's very painful
and uh
it's unbelievable that something like
this happens in the 21st century
uh with so many war crimes and we are
also knowing that in mariupol
there could be and other places that
could be even worse
because there are many people there and
there is no access to that city right
now so it's surrounded and air strikes
are there all the time
there is just the hope of some magic and
i hope that we will see more people
lisa
um
the russians in the form of president
putin
have said this is all staged and uh they
are asking for an emergency session of
the un security council they feel that
they are the victims in all of this what
would you say in response
it's such a terrible cynicism
but you know in the second world war
nazi and society in nazi germany we're
all also saying that killing people is
fine and this is for the better like
goal of of everyone
um
it the question is how did these
societies end up and that political
leadership of russia that they can so
easily justify the crimes and the
murders and saying that it was just
staged
um it's
like it's very hard to explain this and
uh
i wanted also to mention that you know i
lost my apartment because my apartment
is not far from bucha also like the
whole building is destroyed
and
i don't know what happened with
neighbors because some of them managed
to live on the first days they were
lucky but others who were hiding in the
basement there is no connection to them
so it's like you always wait uh for good
news but you also are ready to hear
some very very bad
news because many people
unfortunately were killed in that towns
lisa we've been um hearing from vladimir
klitschko
in an interview
that has been verified by skye
describing what has happened they
described it as genocide i think we can
just have a listen to what he said and
then we'll talk about it further
what happened here
and everywhere in ukraine what is
happening
this is not special operation this is
not military objects this is civilians
they've been shot in the head with a
tight hands behind their back
this is genocide of the ukrainian
population
what do you want the west to do lisa
to act
to
end this world we need security
guarantees right now that
our territory can be protected but that
guarantees should be real not only just
on paper it means that
if something is going to happen then
then there should be real military
assistance coming
we really want the west
um to be
realistic and to know that we the only
way to win in this world to win humanity
is to show strength there cannot be any
like compromise with putin at at this
stage
we are not going to make any compromises
with our territory and the people who
already
died for
defense of of ukraine um
like
my president and i think not a single
ukrainian can agree that we can uh
give away
a piece of territory just for the sake
of possible peace uh first of all we
don't believe in that peace on that
norms uh and conditions and second it
would be very
um naive to think the way that putin
will stop he is not stopping and we see
that he continues bombing and airstrikes
in in most of the cities there was uh
yesterday an airstrike in chernobyl it's
one of the most let's say safest western
cities there were not many
attacks there so
putin continues that which means
we need to act very very seriously to
help ukraine to get that military
strength even more and to win and kill
this evil of war
a lot of western countries
and academics feel that what's happening
in your country
are war crimes do you think that
president putin will ever stand trial
well i i hope that president putin
will be on trial for this war crimes
i'm sure that his surrounding and uh
those
who committed these terrible things
uh one day there will be justice and
they will
pay that price but when it happens it
happens uh
only if if we fight for it
because i keep hearing unfortunately
from some even foreign politicians that
oh maybe we can make still a deal with
putin what kind of deal you can make
with the war criminal you know there
there couldn't be any deals with these
people there is only one way whether we
when whether we stand for for kindness
for security for peace for for humanity
or
those who say this they also support
where crimes then
okay
thank you for taking the time to join us
this morning thank you